hello chair can you hear me
yes i can thank you paul thank you
so it's telling me on my screen that um
we're live
um richard um it's
not quite half past so we can't actually
start the meeting until 10
30 and i'm still waiting for it to come
up and to get the okay from the comms
team so
um we definitely can't start to hard
past um
okay because that was what we put in the
agenda yeah sure no problem
so
yes
uh richard could i ask her a question
sure cancer doors go ahead uh
i'm slightly concerned i'm not showing
on uh on youtube
but maybe that'll change when i've asked
the question let's see
no i can see you perfectly well on
youtube
and no no on the screen here
it's probably a little bit delayed
because you didn't have your video on
just now
okay i'm on now thank you very much okay
you're welcome
it's now uh 10 30 if you'd like to stop
meeting
thank you very much sarah
good morning this is a standards meeting
of team bridge district council
i am councillor richard keeling the
chairman
this committee in attendance are
councillor haines
present councillor pert
present council nuttall
president thank you we also have two
independent persons
one talc parish representative
officers present the monitoring officer
the deputy monitoring officer democratic
services lead officer
democratic officer and the investigator
also present is councillor malone and
councillor dawes
the reason for this meeting is for the
committee to consider the independent
investigation report
which councillors had and read of some
70 pages
which for transparency i have requested
it to be in the public domain
published on the tdc website with this
agenda
this hearing is regarding the alleged
breaches of the code of conduct
by council malone
the relevant legislation and protocols
the localism act 2011 section 27
1 of the localism act 2011 places a
relevant
authority under a statutory duty to
promote and maintain
high standards of conduct by members and
co-opted members of this authority
under section 27 2 of the act a relevant
authority must
in particular adopt a code dealing with
conduct
that is expected of members and co-opted
members of the authority which
they are acting in their capacity
team bridge district council is a
relevant authority its code
of conduct is included in the council's
constitution last
updated in may 2018.
this investigation is carried out in the
relev
in relation to the district council's
code of conduct
and under its arrangement for dealing
with complaints against councillors
the code of conduct the following
paragraphs of the district council's
code of conduct are relevant
4.1 to behave in such a way that is a
reasonable person would regard as
respectful
4.2 not to act in a way which a
reasonable person would regard as
bullying or intimidary
4.7 not to bring the office of
counsellor or the council
into distribute the protocol
on members officer relations
the council's constitution includes a
protocol to guide members and officers
in their relations with one another
compliance with this protocol
is not specific requirements under the
code of conduct nevertheless
it is requirement of the council set out
in its constitution
that officers and members should treat
each other with courtesy at all times
all councillors have attended induction
training
which is included the code of conduct
and now move to the agenda
agenda item one apologies for absent
i have council bulovant and councillor l
patrick
item two declaration of interest
when any councillors have a declaration
of interest please
see no indication
item three the standards complaint if i
can go to the investigator please
to give a summary thank you
yes thank you chair this investigation
was
initiated by the monitoring officer in
response to concerns expressed by
members and officers
about the conduct of councillor malone
and another councillor
in the case of councillor malone i
considered eight instances of conduct
in section five i've set out my findings
of facts
where matters were disputed i've come to
conclusions on these
on the basis of my findings of fact i
have assessed council malone's conduct
in relation to the council's code of
conduct
and i deal with the eight instances in
turn in section six
regarding the newton says no website
i found that council malone's actions in
establishing the website
took place before he was elected and
were therefore in his private capacity
after the election council malone wrote
and added a notice to the website
and i found he did this in his role as a
councillor
the notice called for the careers of the
people who devised the local plan
to be thrown into a plague pit this
refers to senior managers
and planning officers and the call is
for their careers to be ended
i found that this did not treat those
officers with respect
and therefore councilman alone failed to
follow paragraph 4 1
of the call of fonda
council malone's facebook post up of
24th of september
reported on the climate change briefing
it was crudely insulting to the managing
director
it accused him of an improper
relationship with the landowner
and of making up housing figures
it described the managing director and
planning officers as vandals
who were unfit for office and it called
for their dismissal
i consider that the post was insulting
to the managing director
and planning officers i believe an
objective observer would find the review
wholly inappropriate and not befitting
the office of a councillor
i found that council malone's post was
grossly disrespectful to officers
he therefore failed to follow paragraph
four one of the code of conduct
he brought his office into and therefore
failed to follow paragraph 4 7 of the
code
in his post of the 28th of september
council malone
referred to a planning issue in south
hams
he described this as trying to get stuff
built before the elected members knew
about it
he then directly associated this
approach with a named team bridge
planning officer
i consider this was unfair discourteous
and damaging to her he did not treat the
officer with respect
and therefore failed to follow paragraph
four one of the code
on the 4th of october council malone
posted a review of the warba options
workshop
he likened the process to beating up
your gram
his account was lapping punching and
death
and the language he used was violent and
aggressive
council malone attributed the review
process described in these terms
directly to a named planning officer
he said it was a heinous moral crime
that any normal human being would feel
ashamed of perpetrating
and aren't these people just beyond
content
i found that by associating a violent
and aggressive metaphor to the planning
officer
and criticizing her morals as he did
councillor malone was grossly
disrespectful to her
he therefore failed to follow paragraph
four one of the code of conduct
by portraying the options workshop as he
did and naming the planning officer
responsible for
it council malone caused significant
concern
and upset the post was intimidatory to
the officer and therefore he failed to
follow paragraph or
off the code i believe an objective
observer would find council malone's
conduct
wholly objectionable and not befitting a
counsellor
i found that he brought his office into
disrepute and therefore failed to follow
paragraph four
seven of the code of conduct
council malone's post attracted a number
of comments from others
they were personally critical and
offensive to the named planning officer
council malone liked one of the comments
council malone's facebook page is his
principal public face as a counselor i
believe
an objective observer would expect him
to take some responsibility for the
comments
placed on it they would regard
not doing so as a deficiency in his role
as a counselor
i found that by endorsing an offensive
comment
and by allowing others to remain on his
facebook page
council malone brought his office into
disrepute
he therefore failed to follow paragraph
four seven of the code of conduct
the facebook post of 16th of october is
in general terms and does not criticize
particular individuals
i did not find that he breached the code
in this post
the article in the people's republic of
south devon of 21st
october was copied from council malone's
facebook page
it was written in his official capacity
the article describes teen bridge
liberal democrat
councillors in insulting terms
council malone is not disagreeing with
liberal democrat views or policies
his comments are aimed at the people
concerned and their personal
characteristics
i found that he was disrespectful to the
counselors and therefore failed to
follow paragraph four
one of the code
in his facebook post of 22nd of october
council malone criticizes the planning
officers
dealing with the planning appeal of the
woolbrand development
as well as mocking the officers he
suggests that they have deliberately
sought to weaken the council's case in
the appeal
and have lent a friendly hand to the
developer
these casual and unsubstantiated
allegations
strike at the integrity of the is
concerned
and are undermining and damaging to them
i found that councillor malone was
disrespectful to the planning officers
and he therefore failed to follow
paragraph 4-1 of the coves
malone's facebook post of 29th of
october
also concert concerned the woolbra
appeal
the planning committee had discussed the
council's case in the appeal
council malone reported that it was
reported
it was proposed to hand control over to
a named planning officer
he wrote his thanks that the fantastic
miss fox
did not get the keys to the hen house
today
the clear message of the post was that
the named planning officer
could not be trusted to carry out her
professional duties
i could consider this was personally
insulting demeaning
and undermining to the office are
concerned
i found the council alone was
disrespectful to the officer
and therefore failed to follow paragraph
4-1
the code of conduct
i considered that the council's protocol
a member officer relations was relevant
to this investigation the fundamental
principle of the protocol
is that members and officers should
treat each other with courtesy at all
times
i found that council alone failed to
treat officers with respect
in six instances and was intimidatory in
one
it follows therefore that he also failed
to follow the protocol
in these instances so in summary chair
i found that council malone failed to
follow the code of conduct
in seven instances with a total of 11
breaches
the details of these are summarized in
section 7 of my report
thank you chad thank you thank you for
that
uh council malone you provided us with a
witness video
um which all councillors have seen
some 20 minutes long you provided that
yesterday for us
and i'm sure councillors have all had
time
and i've spoken to them and they have um
viewed that
council malone do you wish to issue a
statement with relevance to the alleged
breaches
you mean my opening statement
as i said do you wish to issue a
statement with relevance to the
alleged breaches uh if you mean my
opening this is not a council chamber
sorry what this is not a council chamber
where we're discussing things in general
we're discussing here
at the relevance of the alleged breaches
this is why we're here
okay i'm not sure what you mean i have
an opening statement if you'd like to
hear it
please carry on okay
thank you uh on the morning
of october 20th 2019 my colleague
and ward partner counselor janet
bradford
said good morning to councillor jackie
hook
jackie hook one of my accusers in this
70 page rap
sheet pointed at myself and
councillorated doors and replied
in full hearing of the chamber it would
be if it wasn't for those pricks
now i thought to myself that doesn't
sound very respectful
we
and i was i admit trying to work out
what respect was
as someone with asperger's who has lived
their entire life on the spectrum
i maybe struggle to filter my opinions
sometimes
and i do sometimes wonder what people
mean
when they bring up nebulous or
unquantifiable concepts
that exist well outside my sometimes
obsessional binaries
of true or false good or bad real or
fantasy right or wrong but i did think
to myself
whatever respect is that's probably not
it so i thought to myself
should i bring a code of conduct case
against jackie hook apparently that's
what you're supposed to do
but i thought no because the world's on
fire
isn't it and there's probably not time
for me to worry about my little ego
and the council has a deck hole in it
doesn't it so there's probably not
enough money
for the monitoring officer to pay a wide
boy mercenary
who's been fingered in a massive
safeguarding scandal
to go and harass her for me and then i
remembered that i'm a liberal
like a proper classical liberal who
believes that every man and woman has
the right to speak their mind and i
remembered the words of voltaire
if you want to know who controls you who
oppresses you
then just ask yourself who you are not
permitted to criticize
and i thought you know what if jackie
hook thinks we're pricks and she's
prepared to say so
in front of the whole chamber then god
speak to her god bless her frankly
because for one thing
she's expressing just how unintimidating
she finds us
and secondly how refreshing that she's
actually saying something she genuinely
means
thank you please continue
thank you councilman um moving on
uh do any of the officers sorry any of
the
councillors present um or committee
members
wish to speak to the investigating
officer
or counsel malone at this point
councillor haynes
thank you chairman um is it in order to
ask councilman
about the witnesses that we saw the
comments from yesterday
absolutely yes okay um
well obviously the witnesses gave a very
sincere
opinions of uh council malone um
but my question to him is my question to
him is why
he actually chose those people as
witnesses the issue
is an objective observer
that's the comment investigator made
that how an objective observer
would view it well where do i go and
find an objective
and where and what is that please
council malone
let councillor haynes finish please
the definition no the definition of an
objective
of objective is a person or their
judgment
not influenced by personal feelings or
opinions
in considering and representing facts
now the fact is that those
members of the public that were brought
forward as witnesses
did express opinions about the
development
in na3 so my question is
do you consider them to be objective
observers
uh they are the people who were the
audience to the thing that i was that i
wrote
and the thing that i'm being held up
here about
they were the people that uh
read that that saw that when you say an
objective observer
uh somebody who is completely
disinterested wouldn't care one way or
the other about anything that we're
talking about
thank you i suspect that what you think
what you mean by an objective observer
is someone who agrees with you
councillor haynes well chairman i'm
trying to be entirely objective about
this
clearly the audience of what was being
posted wasn't just the people
that council malone thinks he's sending
it to others would have read it as well
uh i think the concept of an objective
observer is somebody in the sort of
in the realms of law i think it's the
one that used to be referred to as the
the man on the clapper omnibus for
example so we're talking about somebody
in
full knowledge of the facts who is
objective that doesn't have
any particular opinions on the case so
is
was talking about concepts earlier as a
concept that is what is seen
as the objective observer can i go on to
ask another question please related
witness said um the um one of the
witnesses i think was the one at the end
um referred to sort of about always
being truthful
uh always telling the truth and um just
now council malone talked about
the binary true or false now can i ask
him if
the um statement he made about the south
hams planning case
whether he would accept that his lack of
understanding or knowledge of the
planning system meant that he made the
statement
that actually was untrue no i don't
think it was untrue i think it was
perfectly true
tim darsley has tried to say put it in
sort of planning bureau spread
and say oh you haven't understood this i
understood the essence of it entirely
and that was what i was talking about
thank you councilman
um i have the parish representative um
please unmute yourself oh and
ask away through the chair please thank
you chairman
um i've read the investigators report
and i thought that there were some
fundamental admissions from them
i mean i would have expected him to have
said who he is
who he works for and why he's competent
to
lead the investigation secondly
i'd expected something about his
conflicts of interest
i believe he was recommended by hoey
ainskoff associates
who are uh consultants to the council
but i don't know whether that causes a
conflict okay
i can clarify a little there uh george
um
hoey and hoey um work for the government
as such so and he is an associate of
that
um i can ask uh the investigator if he
wishes to elaborate
on that um somewhat if he wishes to
to me um we've gone over this at a
previous
meeting so um i wonder whether the
investigator would like remember
being suppressed at the previous meeting
what would you like me to clarify chair
uh just to clarify um as the parish
representative
as requested um if you wish
well my my my competence for carrying
out
um such an investigation stems from my
experience as a
senior local government officer
occupying the role of monitoring officer
in a southwest district council for
something like
10 years
i was referred to the council through
hoey ayn scoff i work i work with them
we
we share contacts and and knowledge
um really it's nothing there's nothing
more than that my understanding is
you've been with
us for about four years doing reports
and uh the monitoring officer um
requested uh hoey noe to
to find someone and they they found you
can you tell us a little bit about the
safeguarding scandal he was involved in
that the monitoring
refused to consider councilmember and
the reason why we're here it would be
nice because
by yourself so if we can um
oh one sec counselor doors do you wish
to speak
yes thanks uh thanks richard i i mean
it's a very good point that's been
raised by the parish representative it's
a point we tried to raise
uh through the right processes last week
and was disallowed and i i think it's
wholly appropriate
for the council uh and for the standards
committee
to have some introspective nature to
itself and be sure
of the basis that these charges against
myself and liam alone were being brought
we did
do our own due diligence on the
investigator it caused
huge concern i'd like the reassurance
that every single member
of the standards committee has read that
digested that
and is still okay to proceed on this
basis because
i think this thank you council last week
are going to be looked at in great
detail
and please richard i hope so not cut
across me
because the tenet of free speech is the
single
starting point of democracy and this
this whole process is an affront to
democracy
all we want is to be heard all we've
ever wanted is to be heard
thank you thank you councillor dawes i
mean
if i look at the report in general there
are
findings of facts that you agree with
council malone with the investigator and
that's what we're going to do
what have i agreed with undisputed facts
no
i have i i put very we will go through
that
as the main i disagree with all of this
well why does it go through a single
point
we will go through the findings of fact
and
paragraph by paragraph and then you can
give your comments there
and i've been very transparent i've
allowed you
to say what you needed to say in as long
as it's relevant
to this alleged breach i won't say a
single thing that's not relevant
thank you thank you so any any further
questions from councillors
um yes parish representative carry on
please
thank you um i would also have expected
uh the report to
include the formal complaints received
because it seems only fair to me that
the uh the council of malone should see
the uh formal complaint so that he can
fully understand
what's been alleged and so he can defend
himself properly
yes and then lastly i'd have expected
the report to contain details of
the investigator's terms of engagement
so there we are there's four thank you
if i can bring in the
monitoring officer um to answer your
questions there
thank you um thank you chairman
um obviously there seems to be some
confusion here and i think we it was
really important obviously that the
committee came
to its agenda but with regards to this
matter
as is clear from the investigators
report concerns were raised with me
it wasn't possible to resolve the matter
informally
because the council concerned wouldn't
engage in a meeting as a result of that
as a monitoring officer and bearing in
mind the council's statutory duty
which to which he referred to promote
and maintain high standards of conduct
amongst its members
an investigation was commenced i am
aware
that the investigator provided a list
having spoken to the individuals who
raised concerns
provided a list to counsel them alone
of the concerns which were raised and
the specific
incidences which he investigated and
discussed and had
interviews with the relevant member and
other witnesses this is what's set out
in report
thank you very much right
moving on now i'd like to go through the
agenda
findings of fact and if we go by
paragraph and paragraph and
council malone i will ask for your input
uh counselor doors you wish to speak
again
yes thank you i did want to come back on
that point because that was key last
week and it's key this week that
we asked clearly to be told what the
complaints against us were
uh we weren't given them uh the it's our
feeling that these
uh hearings are brought forward on
hearsay
however we did then put in freedom of
information requests to try and
understand
by the information that should be by
legal duty given to us
uh just as members of the public let
alone being members of the council
uh team bridge district council has been
ordered by the ico
uh to to deliver that information to us
and has failed in its legal obligations
to do so it is
hamstringing us knowingly and
through no reason at all it isn't
is again uh it's a it's an abusive power
and a friend to our rights
thank you councillor dawes if i can move
forward then
findings of facts councillors and
i'd like to start with the undisputed
facts
as advised by the investigator 5.8
to 5.31 it is the duty of councillors to
be clear what is in dispute if anything
between the investigating
officer and councilman alone so on 5.8
to 5.31
councilman do you wish to make any
comments well on 5.8 to 5.43
all the stuff to do with the nsn website
is inadmissible
tim darsley himself has stated in his
own findings the things put on the
website before we took up our roles as
councillors
are inadmissible now there's nothing on
the website
the very last edit made to that website
was
uh between winning the election and
taking up
our roles as counsellors that was the
last time it was touched
it hasn't had any of us go near it
since then so you know
um it was done
when it was done mostly by me and with
contribution contributions from 10 or 12
others
as a private citizen before we won the
election
after the results were in i made an
attempt to suspend the functionality
and i remember that because it took me
hours and there was a lot of swearing
and i was
quite hungover because we'd been
celebrating the win on the balance of
profitabilities
uh while i was in there i was probably
type that's probably when i typed up the
stuff about we're holding off for now
and uh that square of information
that uh tim darsley is trying to hang me
on
uh but since he's already discluded
things that happened
at the same time as being before
i was officially a councillor he can't
include this
i cannot be a private citizen and
a public figure at the same time i'm not
schrodinger's counsellor
now i can assure you that there is
nothing on their website that was made
after i signed on the dotted line
it it's all it's completely unadmissible
and frankly
it's not as if you haven't got enough
stuff here to go after me on
so i think you're just going to be
wasting your time and i would advise
you i would advise you to strike all
this stuff
thank you council malone we are well
aware of the timeline and that has been
explained by the investigating officer
and he found that
you know what was on the website prior
to you signing up
as a counselor was you as an individual
and you had that right from that moment
that you did sign
to take up the office as a counselor
then you became
under the rules as such um that we all
adhere to
um so moving on is there any uh
counsellor doors yes i i'd like to go to
uh back to point 4.3 actually which is
quite a
quite a key point for me because uh
there's total confusion about the
interviews it's said that
the uh my interview that i have with tim
darzly is used in evidence
uh in this hearing just in terms of
clearing up that confusion
uh the the process was was approached as
a joint investigation
uh into myself and liam alone until i
pointed out we're not
a body that can be held responsible
for each other's actions uh i didn't
agree to be interviewed in relation to
the investigation of liam malone
for clarity i did not sign the statement
as a true record i did not give
permission for it to be published
so 4.3 is knowingly misleading uh
and i'm going to be looking into what
breaches and my privacy tim darzly
has done by undertaking to publish this
and misrepresenting this statement
in a public document yes
and then on on the nsn website
no sorry can we just go back to what
you've just said
yes can i for clarity's sake i can speak
um i decided that this report would
be disclosed and that was because both
yourself and council malone
expressed that everything should be in
the public domain
and that was the only way that you were
going to engage with this process
so i did that i decided that this
this report this 70 page report and your
report of 57 pages
to be go on with the agenda so that it
can be shared so people can see it
as you requested you requested openness
and transparency
and i am doing my very best to do that
counselor
i agree with with the openness and
transparency
what i'm not agreeing with and never
agreed to was for my
interview which i do not stand by in any
instance
to be used in this point now on to the
nsa that counselor doors that's
you know putting that radius here public
record
is my ability to do so on the new and
says no website which liam was just
talking about
i'd go further uh what the newton that
says no website could exist today
it could be written by liam malone uh in
his role as a private individual
it has no bearing on his role as a
counselor if he puts his name at the
bottom of it
as as written by councillor liam malone
then it will probably
be in breach the fact that it is
recognized and so
clear that it has no relevance to this
just leads me and other people to
believe it's only been put in there
to discredit it's only been put in there
to say
look what they said look what they said
wasn't it terrible
uh and and you know there's there's lots
of research and evidence that if you
if you throw these smears out there then
you
end up influencing people emotionally we
have this last week
when councillor pedric was asking me
what would i feel like if it was my
daughter's irrelevant that it was
something else
i cannot go back to a previous meeting
well unfortunately over here
with councillor malone unfortunately
they are modeled together by this
process which is being flawed
from start to finish that that's your
opinion
now we're dealing with findings of fact
here so i'd like to move on
so we're moving forward to 5.32 to 5.49
i know that overlaps what council malone
just mentioned
do you have any comments on that council
malone
sorry 5.1 5.32 this has already been
sent to yourself
it's finding a fax section 5 5.32 to
5.49
um i don't actually have a print out of
that specifically
because it was 70 pages and i wanted to
save the environment
so i don't know what's it to do with
please okay
it's disputed facts five point three two
to five point four three
nsn website uh if it's the nsn website
inadmissible okay thank you is there any
questions from councillors
councilor perd thank you chair uh
councilman
you asked the creator of the website to
suspend its functionality
however his email request had been not
been answered
i can't understand why you didn't make a
phone call
unless you have the expertise to do this
yourself
to make sure that it was taken off uh
just to disambiguate
i would consider myself the creator of
the website
this was just a person who understand
who understood the uh
the code and how the website attached to
its uh domain name
i asked him to disattach the website
from its domain name so
if you went to uh newton says no dot
co dot uk whatever it is um you wouldn't
you wouldn't find anything
that's what i asked him to do but he
wasn't
replying to me um
did i call him i can't remember i'm sure
i probably did
okay thank you would you so sorry
it still remains functional that
website um
it doesn't really remain functional if
you know exactly what
as far as i can work out i mean i
haven't paid
uh for the domain for a long time so it
should just expire
uh and it should have done already but
it it you can
if you know that there's something you
want to find there you can yeah it does
appear that you can find it yeah
um but you can't use a new person
cannot find it and navigate it was the
best i could do at the time
counselor doors just uh just just for
clarity anything that's ever been
published on the internet
is is is traceable it's findable i could
go back to websites i've produced in
in the late 90s and find pretty much all
of that content so it's like publishing
something
it has been published thank you in terms
of council of perth's
suggestion that it should be taken down
that was something that was offered in
good faith
i don't think team resistance council
has the ability
to demand that people unpublish things
they publish
in their roles as civilians
is not the stasi it is not in that
position of power
thank you councillor haines
thank you chairman well matt excuse me
on that
issue um given that council load has
just said about
the person who the technical person who
wouldn't get didn't get back to him and
it
has answered councillor pert that he
didn't uh tried to call him
surely given your new role and your
colleagues
on team bridge council and the fact that
you did try to do that
shouldn't you have exercised due
diligence in actually getting somebody
else
to undertake that um task for you
leaving aside what counselor doors have
just said the fact that the website
could then be
taken down at that stage you having
become councillors
uh shouldn't you have carried out more
actions to achieve that
um as has already been stated i'm not
under any legal obligation to do
anything with the website what i did was
as an
act of faith uh that has been thrown
back in my face frankly
uh yes i did uh i did what i could at
the time to take it down
i didn't actually hear anything beyond
that
until this investigation started
so nothing particularly alerted me
that it was causing a problem but then i
suppose everyone was just uh muttering
about us in the shadows
as they usually tend to do rather than
taking it up with me
thank you councillor malone um i have
some blue hands
uh one's just gone um and the
investigators still got a blue hand up
do you wish to speak
please go ahead yes thank you chair i
just want to clarify this
um the majority of the
um nsn website
councilman is perfectly correct that was
written before he became a councillor
and um that was done in his private
capacity
we have no concerns about that under the
code of conduct
the issue that i was looking at is the
notice
that was put on the front page of the
website which was clearly done
after the election when council done
after the election
before we signed on the dotted line i've
said it in a thousand
times and please please don't over
the wording and the sentiments expressed
in that notice
and the notice alone that i'm concerned
with and that i found
uh breached the code of conduct um just
starting the point
none of us are counselors after the
election are we we become counsellors
when we when we take up our office and
we sign on the dotted line
all of this was done in that interim and
he's already dismissed things done
and at the same session of editing
counseling
as i said counselors here know
exactly when you took office and there
is a timeline between
when you actually were elected and when
you actually sign on the dotted line we
understand that
thank you if there's no further
questions i'll move on
thank you if we can look at 5.47 to 5.49
sorry we have a further question
actually sorry
sorry parish representative uh thank you
chairman
i just wanted to say that various
political parties
do maintain campaign websites
the tory party have the european
research group
the labour party have momentum
so political parties can maintain
websites
for campaign purposes now the problem
that
i see with the nsn website is that the
political party has adopted exactly the
same name
as the campaign group which has caused
confusion and i'd have thought that if
the
political party had adopted a slightly
different name
um newton independence for example
then the campaign website could have
been
maintained and it could have been used
not perhaps by councillors malone and
doors but it could be used by the
other members of their campaign
i think it's quite clear that councillor
malone said that he was solely
responsible
for the setting up of the website and
the contingency we've had we've gone
over this
setting up yes yeah not for all the
content
no okay i believe
last week that uh council malone said
that there were
12 to 13 contributors to the site
so all those other contributors have
been deprived of
a platform to express their their views
thank you they're doing it on our
facebook page
okay councilman thank you moving on as i
said 5.47
to 5.49 the contribution to
the pr sd magazine
comments yeah the statement of fact as
it stands is incorrect um
i well as i've explained before i did
not make a contribution
as it says to prsd which is any case as
a website not a magazine i mean does
does he do any research i seem to
remember the editor
writer api is a one-man operation and
it's a sort of left-leaning blog
about south devon really um
he lifted it and pasted it into a story
entirely of his own volition
i i do remember getting a phone call i
was up in the
in the forest of boland i had very
little reception and he said i
can i take this thing you've written and
i just said if i've written it then yeah
you can
you can have it but i've struggled to
find where he took it from
uh because it's not on my counselor
facebook page
it's actually on my personal facebook
page of october 18
2019. now like many people especially
counselors i suspect i have two distinct
facebook pages one for
actual friends family other people uh in
the comedy and journalism industries
that i've met over the years and i know
in a face-to-face capacity and that's a
private
uh setting on there and the other is a
conduit through which you talk to people
in my world as a counselor
now the editor of prsd isn't someone i
know in my personal facebook
uh and i don't know how he got hold of
the quote
in any event it was not something i had
any control over
so in effect he's taken something that
was intended for my friends and family
and made it a matter of public record uh
you know it's the same thing really as
going into someone's email account and
making a private email public
but it it's not something i put out
there as a counsellor
and therefore i don't really think i
should be being questioned on it as a
counsellor
unless you're going to make the case
that once we take up our offices
we do absolutely everything as a
counsellor
but you know i think it's slightly
ridiculous given the lengths that tim
darsley has gone to to disambiguate
the the things we do as private citizens
and the things we do as counsellors so
you're saying that you don't
you don't know this person that um
facebook i've never met them they phoned
me a couple of times and asked if i
could give them a quote
on something but i they operate as a
freelance
journalist i i suppose on on their own
blog and they find their own stories and
they find their own stuff
okay so your facebook page is open to
anybody to view
no my private facebook page isn't that's
you know people i've uh marked as a
friend
my counselor facebook page is completely
public yeah
so i'm trying to work out how then that
this person accessed your
private personal facebook and and
from it i genuinely don't know okay
thank you
any questions for council malone on that
thank you moving on
findings as to compliance with code
section 6 11.15 to 12.15
and this is to determine whether there
has been a breach of the code of conduct
any comments counsel below sorry
sorry what was that we're going through
now 11.15 to 12.15
on the findings of compliance with code
section six
that you wouldn't see have we abandoned
all the six point some things
this is the list that we've sent you
that we wish to ask questions on
you have i'm happy for you later because
we seem to have
the monitoring officer wishes to say
thank you um yes
chair it may be helpful just to clarify
obviously you've had a look at section
five which sets out the investigator's
findings of fat
and you've had various representations
from councillor malone
and cancer the doors on his behalf and
members have asked questions
you've now obviously moved on to section
six
which is the consideration about whether
or not
there is a breach of the code so in
response to
cancer malone's question no you are
still dealing with section six
and you've identified to him the bits
that you are now looking at
are paragraph 6.5 to 6.11
thank you thank you for the
clarification
do you have any comments on that council
malone so
can you i'll give you a few moments yeah
yeah no rush
i can't quite find it can you remind me
what the charge is on that please
well if we 6.5 to 6.11
yeah we can go with that one yes um
it's about the news there's no website
yeah why are we still talking about the
website
and why are we still why are we still
stuck on this because
you know we're doing this whole thing
because tim darsley says oh
i find that this was done then and i
find
that this was done at another time if i
can clarify why is he finding it
does this whole thing rest on the
chronology doesn't it so
you know did it appear on the website
before or after i signed on the dotted
line that's all
we've gone over that well we seem to be
going over it again
because tim darsley presents no evidence
either way does he he
uses phrases like on the balance of
you probabilities based on what what
scientific metric is he using
in this context does he mind the source
code though
we've gone over that because there is
one and if he looked at it he'd find
that
i'm telling the absolute truth on this
he's got no evidence he's got no
methodology
i mean how is this taken seriously i
find thank you for your comments
it's a digital document it can be
dissected
hire someone who can look at that
instead of
what's he what's he using tea leaves or
shaping trails
thank you very much website
we move on please ask
questions of council malone
no i have none so 6.12
is repost of 24th of september
any comments cancel them alone
24th of september are we looking at 6.12
here
that's correct right
you're asking me about why i
said that phil shares is a vandal unfit
for office
am i am i i'm asking for your comment
please
yes okay there's a very good reason why
i said this
is because phil shears is a vandal who
is not fit for office
i asked my constituents if they felt
this description was fair
they all said it was this is what they
believed to be true it's what i
believe to be true so the question
really is if you expect me to withhold
from the electorate facts
that i and they hold to be true
and whether you expect me to lie to
people in order to preserve your ideal
of respect
i promise to tell people the truth as i
see it
and that's a promise i intend to keep
now i apologize only
if that makes me a bad example of a
sitting member on timbridge district
council
thank you councillor malone any of the
committee
councillors wish to speak council doors
i'll come back to you in a second
nope counselor doors uh yes i think i
think
what we're dealing with here is is the
throughout the whole thing
apart from the 50 minutes on the news
there's no website the actual charges
uh it's the use of language and uh and
how that's interpreted
uh and i think we'll all acknowledge
that uh the curse of the malone
has a propensity to communicate
in a direct manner uh that is healthy
uh that is what it is uh and that needs
to be
accepted by the committee that needs to
be accepted
by the investigator but if we go into
that specific point and vandals not
not fit for office if we look at what
actually that means
about nature wildlife are being
knowingly destroyed penn
hill park highway and a3 they're not fit
for office
and that's the view of the residents you
probably saw
are you saying that it's disrespectful
because it's not true
or are you saying that it's
disrespectful because even if it were
true
it can't possibly be said
you i'm asking the questions here
councilman i think this is a very
important point to clear out the
because we we need to know the facts of
this matter
moving on to 6.2 have any comments on
that please
to six what sorry 6.2 there is somebody
who wants to make this two hands up to
speak
um
they're stuck up i think the
investigator do you wish to speak sir
no no and parish representative
sorry you'll have to unmute yourself
no you're shaking his head no counselor
doors i'm chairing this meeting
thank you very much 6.2 councilman alone
do you have any comments uh
it's very complex because uh it's six
point two or six point two
zero we were just at six point one six
point two zero
if we wanted to zero this is frankly
um
uh my answer to that and it's going to
be my answer to a lot of this
is yes but it's true though isn't it
okay any questions for counseling alone
from the committee
no i have not 6.21
to 6.27 facebook post of the 28th of
september
council malone do you have any comments
on that
[Music]
i'm sure i probably do
[Music]
can i just um because i i mean a lot of
these repetitions
agenda please counselor yeah i know but
a lot of it is somewhere so
i think there's two points i need to
make that will reply to the whole thing
and we can say
you save a lot of time okay far away so
there's two key points that i i think i
need to make because it's just going to
keep
being the same thing now first of all
trying to claim that certain things are
verboten
and that we must not say them that
anything negative is disrespectful and
therefore illegal is it
is actually a breach of our democratic
right to represent the people of our
wards
yeah i'm the leader of a political group
founded on the principle
the principle that this council is led
by vandals
who are not fit for office that's our
constitution that is how we the people
that is our ad pluribus unum right
this is the whole reason why we put our
waders on and strolled into this whole
murky pond
and you can't expect us not to regularly
repeat our guiding principles
we didn't join the council because we
have a
massive respect for it we joined it
because we think it needs turning inside
out
and if you don't want us saying that
then you're going to have to rule our
group illegal and i don't know what
tools the electoral commission
will give you to do that but that's what
you're going to have to do because
that is the essence of our group and i
cannot square that circle for you
and i won't be able to wear it for you
in all the other charges
but political discrimination is a thing
we can fight in law now
key point two key point two and i will
be brief
uh tim stars does he stay you can do a
summing up i think that's what you're
reading now isn't it no i'm not it's not
a song
i'm not summing up but he hangs a lot of
this on his belief that an objective
observer
would recognize the review as grossly
disrespectful to councillors they would
be surprised
et cetera et cetera et cetera now you
know i read this to a few my
constituents and once they'd finished
laughing their response was
unequivocal they don't find it
disrespectful because it's true
they're not sometimes alone
they don't find the review wholly
inappropriate they find it amusing and
truthful
as for not befitting the office of a
councillor you don't get to say that
subjective nonsense who goes to say what
the benchmark of a councillor is
it's not you it's the electorate they
made that decision
can i just say something councilman they
voted for me
we're going off where are my
characteristics and they've
going off from what the reason why we're
here and
we're going to say something now at this
point won't we so now it's out there
thank you council malone
you know i've been a councillor for a
couple of years and i've been in the
same situation where i've been
disagreeing with officers on planning
applications which
that's the crux of the matter and and
the residents in my community didn't
want
a certain development and i i fought
um and put across you know a good uh
a good reason why that development
shouldn't have gone ahead
i don't think you agree when you
disagree i mean please put in an
amendment and you want to
move paragraph five to the end we regard
this
as an environmental atrocity thank you
thank you councilman can i just get
across my point please
but i in no way insulted officers
belittled them in no way did i think
that that was productive
in getting them on board with me to say
to them
this is not the right application this
is not correct
i i had no way did i think by insulting
these officers
that i i would get them on my side and
this is something
i haven't insulted them i've told the
truth they have chosen to find that
insulted
breaches at the moment and this is what
we're here to decide
um so i'm trying to put across to you
you know that
um we need to move on anyway counselor
doors
i just shed some light how we got to
this point and i know we know
we've had no no no richard you you just
gave us something up of you
representing your electric interest
which i would take my hat off to you
well done
and we got to this point we never all do
that yeah yeah we
well when you say we all do some
counsellors do
you do i do the we got to this point
because we were members of residence
associations
who had been duly ignored they put
forward very good
reasoned arguments and they had not been
heard the only way
this has cut through is because we have
taken a
direct approach that has been very
effective
now the fact that's upset people well we
are sorry or maybe we're not even sorry
it
is effective it is democracy i'm afraid
team bridge district council just has to
accept this
right this whole waste of time and
standards hearing is indeed a fast i
think i need to get back onto the agenda
members of this committee need to look
in the mirror and be
absolutely sure that due process has
been followed
because we should never have gotten to
this point
well i differ from you on that council
doors because
as i said in in previous
uh conversations that
back in november of last year you had
the opportunity to go and
speak with the monitoring officer um
and and you declined so i'm not going to
go over that
now you've raised that want an
explanation why that meeting wasn't
attended
well you did try to give me one well
we're in another hearing where it's just
been raised again so
yeah would you like an explanation why
that meeting wasn't attended
not not from you but from councillor
malone probably at the end we can have a
discussion on that
so let's move on please um
any questions for councillor malone
so back on the agenda we go to i think
particularly
um i know but he can't seem to get his
hand down i'm afraid
it's set and also the investigator has
and i've accepted that there we go it's
gone off
they they if they wave their hand i can
see them on the screen so don't worry
about that
so councilman alone 6.28.46
facebook post of 4th of october
do you have any comments on that 6.26
28 6.28 to 6.46
give me a second
um sorry i just have to let the postman
and i will be with you in two seconds
okay um right is this my granny bashing
piece
do you have any comments well as long as
i know what i'm talking about yeah
um yes i have lots of comments what
specifically would you like me to say
i mean first of all a lot a lot there's
a lot of stuff in here that
that shouldn't be here um well that's
not
up to you well okay but let me just
explain why i think that
is that okay um i'd like your comment on
it
yeah okay first of all 6.29 the language
used
is aggressive and violent now that's
just plain silly
there's no such thing as violent
language was the blinding of gloucester
in king lear
done in violent language it was was was
you know montgomery's
account of the battle of el element was
that was that in violent language of
course
of course it wasn't there's no such
thing as violent language they were
there there were things written in lucid
language that describes violent events
language is neutral it doesn't become
imbued with the properties of its
subject i mean it's just a silly thing
to write i can't believe it's written
there
if i write a stroganoff recipe is that
written in delicious language
thank oh yeah i think we should arrest
andy mcnabb because he's written an
awful lot of things in violent language
thank you councilman there's other
things the committee wish
to to question councilman 6 30
i'm charged with saying that she rolled
her eyes
uh she did roll her eyes i saw it are
the officers so sacrosanct that we can't
say they rolled their eyes
have a day off 6 31 michelle luscombe
said she was upset by some graffiti
how is that my business neither are her
relations with her family
6 30 32 councillor jackie hook told me
the review was offensive
well who rattled her cage it's nothing
to do with her
thank you councillor malone councillor
jackie huck believed
his comments fed and multiplied
dissatisfaction with the council
that is offensive that reminds me
of the when the magister regime in
ethiopia
said bandaid shouldn't have sung that
song because it just made people realize
they were hung
along well i just wonder if some of
these witnesses realize
how idiotic they sound no rest of it
roll on any of the committee
have any questions for council malone
nope moving on six point four
seven to six point four nine
posts of 16th of october councillors
i'll come back to you in a second
uh comments please counsel them alone
are we still on the same i did actually
want to talk about
there was actually a no breach found in
this one so oh well i just like you
it's a beautiful day we're wasting 2.5
i'm sorry i've just councilman's asked
to move on
i know but i wanted to speak i had my
handbag no if councillords wants to
speak
let's not move on
council doors thank you very much
quickly yeah quickly i'd just like to
talk give some context as to why we got
into that position how the wolverine dpd
meeting happened
and why there was such level of
dissatisfaction that it was simply
reflected in a post that mr malone
counselor malone wrote the the meeting
was called
by me i demanded it because there was
there was a dpd but there was again
no engagement with the royal residence
or robert's coastal parish council
i did what i was asked to do by by other
councillors go and knock on the door of
the officers
that's what they're there for engage
with them i did
the officer was very helpful she was
doing her job she was trying to help
she brought people into a meeting the
problem with it was
is the meeting had no basis and when
the meeting finished those
representative groups who've been
frustrated for eight years
were furious were livid that would
nothing had been achieved
all that was reflected in that post was
the continued anger
and frustration of the groups who we
represent
okay thank you councillor doors moving
on
6.5 we're talking about the contribution
to the
prsd um
sorry this is this is this is bonkers
because
yeah you've missed out a whole thing
there's a whole thing here
with the walbra options meeting where
you've accused me of being intimidatory
and you haven't even asked me about how
i answer that charge
you've just moved on through the council
i'm alone
do you want my opinion on this please oh
i've got your opinion
well as you know people are watching
this on youtube and i think it might
have been helpful
if instead of going 6.32 and so on
you actually you know painted the
picture for people and provided some
context
so that they know what i'm answering
because otherwise okay it's just a
string of numbers to people
the people are beating up your granny
which is this
was a satirical take on a horrible
meeting in which people had fought and
say
fought to save war brahil for years were
being asked how they would like it
destroyed
now that is blackly humorous isn't it
uh because everyone who has or has had a
granny
uh likes to think their granny's
precious and would like their granny
protected
so uh a meeting in which an attack on a
granny was being discussed
calmly and rationally with graphs and
diagrams and snacks and cake
it was a perfectly like it was all a
perfectly normal thing to talk about
that's quite a good analogy for a
meeting convene to discuss committing an
environmental atrocity
which is what this meeting was now what
i wrote was a satire
and i i hope councillor keeling you do
understand satire because this is quite
a key point
we've had this discussion before i think
well i don't remember having it
do you understand satire i i do
understand satire
have you read swift's modest proposal i
am not
okay with your kind of well in a modest
proposal
swift wrote that the poor should eat
their children
now he wasn't actually suggesting that
the poor people should butcher and cook
their own children
he was making a comment on how callous
society had become about poverty and
this is exactly the same thing
now ordinary people understood that in
1729
and if people in local governments can't
understand it today
then we've gone downhill a long way
haven't we councilman
i've given you a lot of time during this
meeting okay
can i tell you why this shouldn't even
be a charge
uh can i move on no no this is important
because i shouldn't even be having to
answer this my first communication on
this matter i've asked you karen tricky
called me into her office
she's made a lot she's made a lot of
meat out of me missing a meeting
okay i missed that meeting because i had
absolutely no faith in karen tricky by
that point
but the first meeting that she was
always meeting was this
little smiles and it was like let's get
this sorted out
she asked me to apologize about a raft
of things i said sorry no can do and
then she said
michelle was upset about having been
named in this article
i said you know what her name is not
needed in the story in fact it was an
oversight to put it in
what this was meant to be it was a
carnivalization
a making silly of something terrible so
that we could understand it in a
different way
her name shouldn't have been used and
i'll cross it out as soon as i get home
and that is what i did her the charge of
intimidation is attached to her
net her being named right i took her
name out her name was in that article
for a handful of days
a mere handful and i took it out as soon
as i was asked
and now here we are nine months later
still using her name it's being this is
being broadcast
on youtube with her name what does that
say
about karen tricky had no intention of
protecting the identity of the officer
as she asked me to do
by taking it out because she has used
this
when i assumed that we were finished
with it that it was settled
yeah can we move on council because it's
just i think i've given you enough time
to reply tears if i disrespect you no
one cares if i say the council's rotten
let's say he intimidated the woman who
is doing her job with all the nasty
overtones that has with it
we'll make that stick alone do we have
any questions
and that lot won't get in and we could
all go back to having our questions
alone i think that's enough now let me
know what i needed to say
so thank you uh so any uh committee
members wish
to question council malone
okay moving on
can i follow harry councillor doors
yeah just just yeah quickly and
pertinently in
oh good good in terms yes in terms of
the perception
of that article the article uh was
discussed
at length with other counselors i
remember a conversation with
someone that many of us would have
preferred to be our mp
now sitting in parliament uh he
described
the article as satirical well-written
clearly not threatening
suggested that it probably was an
oversight that the officer was mentioned
that was dealt with it was understood by
intelligible
intelligent and and respected people
whatever respect is uh that it was not
a threatening article it was satire
thank you councillors any questions
moving on um 6.54 to 6.58
uh facebook post 27 of october
councilman do you have any comments on
that this is the prsd
thing again no this is a facebook post
of the 22nd
sorry sorry give me the numbers again uh
6.54 to 6.58
um isn't this the thing where there's no
issue
oh sorry no yeah yeah um
yeah uh
using the phrase our lovely fluffy
planning officers
and referring to them as sparkly
unicorns i'm a little confused by that
because we've just spent half an hour
discussing how he completely failed to
understand irony
in uh a 2000 word essay i wrote about
the warbra options
that was 2000 words of pure sarcasm
that everyone else recognizes sarcasm
but he chose to take
entirely literally and now we have a
little bit of figurative speech
and he's jumped right on it and gone
that's ironic
and insulting um
what side of the english language does
he want to operate on
thank thank you councilman o level or a
level council not all
or preschool i thank you chad i'd
actually
sorry like to get to go back to the
previous section because i don't think
i think it was skipped over thank you
malone question that the 6.5
um the investigators section here is
cool is
entitled councillor malone's
contribution to prsd
um i believe cancer malone has explained
in fact that
the quotation about the liberal
democrats and the rest of it was lifted
from his private facebook
page is that correct councillor malone
that is correct yes
thank you but while we're on that
i would there is actually one thing i'd
like to apologize
right oh oh go ahead councilman go ahead
yeah i mean i i apologize always like
that from the record and i would i would
consider you did because
if you ask me why i wrote those words
we'll be going to a place we can't come
back from
and i can promise you that uh but like
since writing that i've i've met some
quite uh pleasant
liberal democrats who have been very
public-minded
uh very honest very into transparency
and very supportive of us
and i would apologize to them for them
being caught up as sort of collateral
damage
in uh in how i was feeling
that day but if we get to why i wrote
that i think
okay i think we'll leave it to that i
think we've got an apology there
and we'll we'll we'll move on um
right 6.59 to 6.66
facebook post of the 29th of october
if i go into too much detail we'll be
here a lot longer than our
allotted time on zoom so that's
6.59 to 6.6
facebook post 29th of october
six point five nine to six point six six
yeah um
that's sort of a continuation of the
points before that yep that's correct
isn't it um it's a different date it's a
different uh
facebook post
yeah um
it is a different post but it i was
talking about the vote
of the thing that came up in the
previous post
isn't it um okay so i mean
this is um where
tim darsley is uh claiming that i've um
that i've made a terrible statement
about ross eastman is that right
this is a post that you put out on your
facebook
29th of october yes
uh where i said um
that you commented about this the
officers have sort of weakened the
council's case
in a planning appeal for development at
warbler and have lent a friendly
helping hand to a developer yeah okay uh
well
do you know what um martin wrigley of
the lib dems stood up on
october the 29th when this actually came
to the vote
and he asked very eloquently why the
officers were weakening the council's
case against the developer
by trying to withdraw two of our clauses
and put a third one in officer control
uh he actually used the analogy of
weapons he said don't put our weapons
beyond use we'll need them for this
fight
and he said that withdrawing these
clauses would be a gift
to the developers so you tell me how
that statement
is at massive variance with what i said
because it isn't
the only thing that's different is your
willingness to extend understanding and
empathy
towards councillor wrigley which we get
none of no not so counsel them alone
so any questions for councillor malone
um yeah
councillor haines then council doors
yeah thank you chairman well the the
point of the paragraphs that you were
just referring to was the
one where ros eastman was likened to uh
fantastic
this is fox so i don't think it was the
one that counts them alone
okay well that's quite a comment good
that's quite a dashing
uh comparison really isn't it i mean
please councilman don't talk over
councillor haynes
councillor the question then would be
do you think that your remarks about
ross eastman were insulting
to meaning and undermining to her uh
what i do know is that when a3 clears
its final hurdle thousands of animals
will die
an irreplaceable fenn will be poisoned
protected bat species will lose their
food and the tranquility they require to
exist
and three species found absolutely
nowhere else
will not exist anymore now if that's
ross eastman's job to push that through
so be it but i think a fox eating a
couple of chickens
is a very mild analogy for someone
engaged in a project to which my group
is i'm sorry we're back to this again
ideologically and absolutely opposed
now again we can't square the circle can
we
or maybe you have to but it's your
problem and not mine thank you
councilman
okay um i consider this
sorry counselor doors hold on a second
let me just quickly skip
skip over the last one on the protocol
uh there was no breach on that so i'll
go to you council doors because you
weren't going to ask a question of
council malone i presume
i know i was going to back up the
statement that he that it is a matter of
fact that the officers were recommended
recommended very strongly
they did in part two meetings which we
couldn't understand
they sought council's opinion uh which
we weren't allowed to see the basis
they'd sort that opinion though we
requested it
uh it's a material fact that the the
officers
were trying to weaken the position as
martin wrigley pointed out
of the council uh against na3
thank you okay so can i just ask
something it's going to
move actually going to move to um
summing up but uh the independent member
wishes to
uh speak excuse me chair i just need a
comfort break so
uh okay well you're non-voting george
so that's not a problem
i haven't run away okay thank you
i think we'll move on because george is
an independent person there and then
you'll be able to view this
end of the uh video anyway
can i request the same because uh we've
been sitting here for an hour and a half
i i
i'm quickly going to come to a summing
up now councillor doors we need to
move on so i need the lou as a private
citizen
not as accountable yes well there we go
so any any further questions from
councillors to council malone before i
asked councillor malone to
finish up councillor
just like to point out chad on 6.71
the officers have a contractual and
legal duty to be impartial
so it is a legal duty they perform
so to to question the integrity i don't
think is the right thing to do
thank you councillor was there
it was a statement i i think we've made
up okay
councilman would you like to um give us
your
final thoughts statement well i'm great
yeah before you do that sorry um
council nigel raised his hand just a
question
councillor malone please um chairman uh
councilman councillor dawes mentioned
referred to
an issue of language in in all of this
rather than content and one of your
witnesses on the video yesterday
said sometimes counselor malone might
speak ahead of common sense
i just like your comment on on those two
issues please
that a lot of this is in fact about
language rather than content
thank you uh well i don't have a filter
i'm sorry i just
i just don't have a filter i am aspergic
and things just uh go through my brain
and they come out my
my mouth i managed to sort of keep a lid
on it while i'm in the council chamber
and if i do understand respect that's
that's what i do
uh on behalf of you all i hope you're
all very grateful for that um
but if my language is intemperate to you
it's very hard for me to
say anything about that because it is my
personality
but as i keep saying everybody who voted
for me
voted for me knowing my personality they
knew me very well before
before they went to the before they went
to put an x in a box
so that's who i am and that's where we
are
thank you um council malone if you could
um
give us your final um
well i i if you requested yes thank you
i i love a circus as most people do and
i'm very disappointed about all the
stuff we didn't get if we can
keep to the relevance i mean no i mean
mr darsley said that someone posted that
whoever wrote the plan should be shot
and that this was hateful
and hateful and we're not even going to
talk about it that there was
cake gate i'd like to comment that
someone
should choke on their cake and he wanted
to say that that was hateful
too and i i'm disappointed that we're
not going into that because that would
have been a good jumping off point
to discuss why someone has been paid 5
000
pounds to harass me for liking a joke
about
cake you know we have playgrounds that
need repairing we need
dog poop picking up we need all sorts of
things we've got a massive hole in our
finances
this is just aaron nonsense but one
thing that i haven't had a chance to
talk about
was um was this i someone showed me an
old newspaper cutting
uh the other day and this might be a
nice point to finish on
um from november 2008
um somebody else was on five code of
conduct charges
for saying that the officers were out of
control uh
that person was the former leader of the
council and our ex-nemesis
uh jeremy christopher's before he became
leader of the council
he said that the councillors were
hell-bent on building in the wrong
places
they weren't listening to the members
they were building in places
such as one place which is now na1 which
was level
three flood plain now i put it to you
that if a build build build conservative
came to the same conclusion as me 11
years
before i said it and we're talking about
a man
who would quite happily put a tyre
incineration plant on the galapagos
islands
if he got 2 pound 50 and a packet of
rolos out of it
if he came to the same conclusion as me
that the officers are out of control
might there just be
a little bit of truth in it
thank you councilman any further
questions from
uh committee members i'll come back to
you councillor doors
the council of doors and then i'll
as my say yeah thank you thank you
richard uh
i mean i again as has been noted we're
talking about language here and i think
that
the electorate accepted uh liam malone
in fact uh put him in a position of
power to represent them and
uh and through history uh the
power has been held to account by
voltaire by bertolt brett
more recently by jonathan pie and
private eye
uh and and i assume that as liam
pointed out he has no filter i assume
the committee are across their
obligations under the equalities of 2010
i'll restate that these investigations
are politically motivated brought on a
whim
and based on hearsay rather than
complaints bringing them forward is an
abuse of power
thank you uh council malone uh if nobody
else
has any further questions i have one
final question and you did bring this
up uh just a few moments ago about costs
and
um our time here i'm not paid for this
job and
uh the other councillors these are
additional um committees that they sit
on
um normally the chairman is paid i i'm
not paid for this um because i have
other duties
but i i'd like just just to say again
first of november 2019 the monitoring
officer invited you to a meeting which
you refused to attend to discuss the
concerns
and how it might be possible to resolve
them
what what you have to say to that that
you know you could have resolved this
back in november 2019
well going back to the naming thing
karen tricky led me to believe that that
was resolved
in fact she'd taken a screen grab of it
and she's trotted it out here
um i don't trust karen tricky for one
second and neither does
anyone else we've spoken to we've asked
her for freedom of information requests
over and over again some of which would
help us
to have answered these questions that
you've given us
many of them a lot of counselors saying
you keep making these allegations about
blah blah
can you prove them well no because
everything that we've asked for
since we joined this council she has
ignored she is in breach
of the ico now you talk to me
about bringing this council into
disrepute you have a head of
legal who is in legal breach that is
that thank you councilman
i asked you a question you could answer
that question for me
why you did not ask karen tricky why she
why we could have avoided this
if you had at cancer doors i'm not going
to allow you to come in
here i'm asking councillor malone i'm
sure he can
answer this question quite clearly why
you know he could not i've gone to that
meeting
and listened to the concerns and how it
might be possible
i had already listened to all the
concerns at previous meetings
i had told her everything i wanted to
say i did not
trust her one bit and if i could just
expand on that
i don't know if you're familiar with
this
judge moira macmillan
uh ruling robert wakeling versus the
information commissioner
this is something that i hope is giving
karen tricky nightmare
this requires timbers district council
to
release documents going all the way back
to 2006.
and on the back of this the police have
issued a crime
reference number where they told us they
are pursuing
active members of this council for
conspiracy
to commit fraud now
the suppression of documents has become
alone
is in an absolute pit of trouble
and that's why we can't be bothered
talking to karen tricky
and we will never be bothered talking to
karen tricky as long as she remains in
office
i'm talking to council malone here i'm
here
you're here to support him
so no i've decided i have a clear answer
why we didn't attend the meeting on
november the 1st
okay councillor doors go ahead okay so
are you speaking for both of you uh yes
because we were both
invited to a model meeting about uh
joint uh behavioral issues uh supposedly
the reason we didn't attend the meeting
because it was around the point
that liam malone's picture was on the
front page of the mda
uh supposedly he'd made threatening uh
he was he was being invested
investigated by the police
uh for four threats there's there's the
paper
now that's probably the first eyeball
and uh and we wanted to find out where
that came from where that came from in
fact the paper eventually admitted
there was no police investigation you
can't print something without a police
crime reference number but then they
admitted to us that
the case have been put to them the
information had been put to them
from higher in tdc we were subject
to a smear campaign this is fact we have
the evidence to prove it
that is why did you not attend the
meeting we had lost
faith in team bridge district council
both the executive
and the senior manager see that picture
there that's there
from the doors you could have
rescheduled the meeting
i'm sorry but when a smear story that's
complete lies in the paper appears
and it's got my book we have no
complaint by timbridge district council
this picture i posed for at the
welcoming drinks
welcome to our temple of equity and
fairness could you stand over there
we'll take your picture
when the time comes we'll give it to the
newspaper with a whole load of lies
that's the kind of operation this
council is
and that's why we didn't bother with the
meeting because we knew
it's like this is a complete waste of
time this is part of the same process
i'm afraid thank you for your comments
consistent smear comes out the doors
thank you for your comments
today and we will now consider the
matter please press your
leave button many thanks
what a beautiful day you've wasted
you